hi I'm Tom he's Justin and you're here
to listen to us talk about Nintendo
Direct Justin Little Mac little neck I
you know they're not were not a huge
amount of really big announcements from
this but little mac is now going to be a
super smash brothers playable character
it was a really cool trailer like I
enjoyed seeing him come onto the stage
and he's cool I like the part where
Samus was like oh he's a little guy but
then you're thinking he beat mr Sandman
he could beat Samus Aran and he is the
knockout meet her you know he's gonna
he's gonna be knocking some guys out of
the park sure it's pretty cool he wasn't
the only new character that we saw today
we saw SATA seven Niner seven new
character market cart and these are
calling back to the Super Mario Brothers
three days bringing back some some
old-school flavor to mario kart 8 yeah
25 years ago we've learned about Lenny
Cooper and I would get two throws there
will shout at him but I I'm never gonna
be rate having more characters to play
with in Mario Kart 8 and I just really
really want to play this game so I need
more characters the better can I have
the rate the babies I don't like the
babies they give me the coop who doesn't
like the baby I don't like I don't like
the babies smell sweet you today so we
also saw some ex the untitled project
from the last the Xenoblade Chronicles
makeup it's hard to show combat in an
RPG in like a five-minute like number
first of nonsense but that game still
looks gorgeous and there's max and we
saw a lot of other things that are
coming out soon that we know are going
to be right on the horizon none of this
was far reaching probably saving that
for e3 for the really big stuff but
donkey kong country tropical freeze that
comes out really soon there's a little
kid in bayonet Oh with silver blue corn
rows for some reason and one of the more
interesting things they had was a kind
of baseball mini game with a very unique
microtransaction model yeah it says four
dollars and you say what about lower
than that rusty and then you get it for
cheaper yeah you can haggle in the game
to get a lower price that's kind of cool
I can't like that and I like winding it
up they finished out with some nes remix
to right here which was a cool game i'm
glad they're bringing that back again
also with some super mario brothers
three characters so yeah and there's two
super mario brothers too
you and a remix of Super Mario Brothers
where you go from right to left so
there's some cool downloadable games
there's a thousand want spikes there's
moon chronicles it's a first person
shooter and there's treasure knocks
which looks pretty neat yeah they have a
lot of really interesting offerings on
the eshop channel and some of it you can
download right now including the remake
of steel diver but you know be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot for all your
continuing Nintendo Direct needs follow
us on twitter follow us on Facebook
thanks a lot